certains pays qui cherchent à jouer un
rôle sur la scène internationale dès les
premières semaines de l'invasion russes
en Ukraine redchep Taek et andoan s'est
posé en médiateur dans ce conflit le
président Turca adopté ce qui est
officiellement vu en Turquie comme une
position neutralité active auprès des
deux camps bonsoir à vous cerise sudrez
le dieu vous êtes à Istanbul pour France
24 cerise alors l'urgence est ailleurs
en ce moment Turquie on le rappelle le
pays est toujours en deuil après le
séisme du 6 février dernier mais tout
doucement la diplomatie se remet en
marche le président turc s'est entretenu
tout à l'heure avec son homologue
ukrainien
oui alors il faut rappeler qu'on est un
peu plus de deux semaines après les
terribles séismes qui ont ravagé la
Turquie ils ont fait plus de 44000 morts
donc d'ailleurs la l'Ukraine et la
Russie ont envoyé des des sauveteurs
mais le ballet diplomatique continue et
le jeu géopolitique commence à reprendre
ses droits comme vous le disiez un reset
à perdwan a eu le président ukrainien ou
le dîner au téléphone cet après-midi
alors il a avec lui évoqué la nécessité
d'arriver à un accord de paix il a
ensuite eu le président Poutine au
téléphone il lui a dit globalement la
même chose qu'il fallait arriver à une
paix qu'il fallait épargner des visuels
et ensuite Emmanuel Macron a aussi
appelé redgéon alors lui là insisté soit
le fait qu'il fallait mettre la pression
sur la Russie qu'il fallait l'isoler sur
la scène internationale donc on le voit
la scène est dramatique en Turquie mais
le vieux international reprend peu à peu
ses droits merci beaucoup cerise